I've been thinking about doing this
for a long time Raphtalia's mellow that was destroyed by the waves Let's
make it a symbol of us who are on par with each
other In addition to Lee's match, new recruits are loaded
and trained here to be equal to the heroes
If you do that, you
'll have two people from now on,
Naofumi-sama,
more than that, it
's like this, it's as if Nanami-sama is paying attention so that you don't have to worry about it, isn't it
Cluster Yanaru 9-san and Terry-san?  When the wave came again, I absolutely rejected it with tears
So I don't know if I learned it It's out of print
I can't meet
you, it's me I hated it--nyan--Nyan--
I just thought that Lord Noumi was
gone.  That's what I was thinking about, I'm
going because I didn't move
forward It's already Mr. Moon's apology
Before, I was certainly hesitant,
but now I'm different
That's why I'm here
Karamichi I met Raphtalia, so I found the meaning of fighting against the waves
I met Hero and Melty, so I decided to fight for my friends After
becoming many other people, I will protect this world as the Hero of the Shield
That's why this is the starting point
And the place we'll return to
Mr. Bun, will you be my key from now on?